as they waited for the verdict
minneapolis
braced
[Music]
[Applause]
the tents there exploding with emotion
people breaking down they did it
justice for george floyd and a ruling
that told black citizens
they matter
but no one was more anxious than george
floyd's brother
representing the family in court i can
get sleep now
i paced back and forth before i even
went into the courtroom
and i sat in one spot in the corner the
same spot by the trash can i always said
it and i prayed
and i prayed for like 30 minutes and the
verdict came back
when the jurors came out guilty guilty
and guilty and i just couldn't believe
it
because african-american people we never
get justice we feel like it's just
us
people spilled into the streets drivers
stopping their cars to join the
celebrations
[Music]
george floyd's girlfriend came to see
the history made
from her immense loss i miss floyd so
much you know it's hard to
it's hard to think about um how i feel
but
i do know that i'm really
hopeful for change right now i feel like
this has just
opened up a door for so many people
to have their cases reopened to have
people get justice for
their last loved one this ruling has
given a community
still hurting some much needed hope
today is another step to justice
for all black people and colored people
around the world
going forward we will hope to see a
change we'll hope to see
we'll hope to see people like us police
and the police and people marched
perhaps feeling that little bit more
protected
this guilty verdict is an important step
towards healing for this community
but it's also a verdict of what society
will and won't accept
it's how change happens
it's a moment owned by a community who
fought for the justice
they were owed sally locke with sky news
minneapolis